we need somebody in the White House who
absolutely is going to be a fighter when
it counts and I did say that there were
some good people on that stage in that
third debate Doug bergham was on that
stage at that
time jokingly Ronda sand is a good
person too I want to go back though to
Nikki Haley's comment from earlier that
she is somehow not responding to the
will of these donors Nikki you were
bankrupt when you left the UN after you
left the UN you became a military
contractor you actually started joining
service on the board of Boeing who's
back you scratched for a very long time
and then gave foreign multinational
speeches like Hillary Clinton is and now
you're a multi-millionaire that math
does not add up it adds
up and when I said they were and paid
for I meant the Republican establishment
not the Democratic like now you have
Reed Hof the person who's effectively
George Soros Jr funding lawsuits across
this country against Donald Trump to
keep him off the ballot funding
left-wing causes